look at me this was not anyone's idea of
what a movie star looked like ever we
were born with success is only others
who point out our failures you can't
ever fail
you'd only learn there's no failure in
comedy there's only learning experiences
because what fails here will work over
here
need motivation watch a top ten and
believe nation what separates heaven my
one would is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a woman who went
from being a high school dropout to one
of the biggest names in Hollywood and
one of the only people to have won a
Tony and Emmy a Grammy an Oscar
she's Whoopi Goldberg and here's my take
on her top ten rules of success joy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one be successful as a human
being we are all born we're born with
success is only others who point out our
failures what they attribute to us as
failure I think the idea that you know
who your inner self
is you know on a daily basis because you
know what's good for you 25 years ago
may not be good for you now so to keep
in touch with that that's the that's the
air
I think the first ingredient for success
because if you're a successful human
being you know everything else is gravy
thank rule number two create your own
opportunities
you started out of the comedian correct
no I started out as a straight actor oh
it's right that couldn't get any work
because people would look and I'd go try
to do some Shakespeare and they go I
move what are you here for I'd say well
I'd like to audition for they go no no
no no no next so I wrote a whole bunch
of stuff for me to do so I could show
people what I was capable of and that
sort of kicked everything off rule
number three my personal favorite be
yourself
well my life is a class if I was to say
it probably teaches that you can be
yourself in an individual if you are
comfortable with not everybody liking
you or how you think if you're
comfortable with going against the grain
if you're comfortable with you know
people making fun or saying really nasty
stuff if you're comfortable with all
that and you can be yourself it's that's
the price the price of being yourself is
you know other people's angst about you
being yourself look at me
this was not anyone's idea of what a
movie star looked like ever you know and
and after it happened you know I would
read that in the paper all the time
what's with the face what's with the
hair why does she look like this why
does she wear high heels was she dressed
like a guy is she gay is she straight
what the hell you know for years and
years and years you know because I you
know I guess she was supposed to be a
little more glamorous and I'm just
Glamour's a lot of work I'm
fundamentally lazy you know III have
dreads because I didn't want to comb my
hair you know it had nothing to do with
rastas and family people like oh you
said I'm not deep I'm this deep I'm busy
I wore sneakers because it was most
comfortable for me you know and who
wants to stand and I use for three or
four hours you know when you could be
wearing sneakers under that dress so
that's what I did
rule number four find your passion
Oberth from birth I knew as soon as I
hit that light I was waving it it's
always been it's it's it's as much a
part of my whole being as breathing I
always knew this was it I know it was
gonna be like this you know but I always
knew that I wanted to act you know there
was never any for me any once and no
you're gonna fail or no there's no place
for you the only thing my mom ever said
to me was you know it may be tough you
know but what isn't you know rule number
five adjust and learn
tody feels was an amazing comic she's
before your time
around lady brilliantly funny got sick
lost a leg went on stage with the
crutches and talked about being without
a leg she eventually died I think it was
of cancer she was amazing
you look at Phyllis Diller Phyllis
talked about not battering per se as we
know it now but abuse you know mm-hmm
and people through osmosis got what she
was talking about you know yeah comedy
is one of those things
it goes beyond color it goes beyond
color somebody without a leg it's gonna
be happy to was was happy to see toady
and said you know if she can still get
up in front of an audience there's no
reason why I can't be seen outside with
a prosthesis or no leg at all yeah you
know mm-hmm so it's really a personal
choice as to whether you want to be your
own person or you want to follow the
back it's your choice the industry has
so much pressure on pigeonholing people
again about the industry you know you if
you need to go over here and work you
make a couple of the adaptations and
what you're doing okay but you do what
you do the idea is to get out there and
do the work
okay you know and if you make little
tiny adjustments here and there okay as
long as they don't you know make you
double over and you go I can't be doing
this
yeah yeah right you said okay I'm gonna
go over here and see what works for this
group see what works for this group see
what works for this group because the
stuff you do in New York you know the
the the breadth of the material that you
do in New York may not be the same
material you're gonna do in Missouri
okay you know yeah make those
adjustments for where you are mm-hmm you
know and put in some look the best
commercial the best way I can say this
Jerry Seinfeld did an American Express
commercial where he's in England and he
does this American thing and it doesn't
go over so through the quickness of
cameras and the magic of Hollywood he
learns about the people and is able to
adapt his material to the audience he's
playing that in fact is what you have to
do every time you go out you got to feel
a room you got to feel what's going on
in you cuz the day you get your period
Krabs you're gonna have a different kind
of night then you would when you don't
have crabs and that has a lot to do with
go say you just got to go out with
what's going on that day and do it and
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't
you can't ever fail you'd only learn
there's no failure in comedy there's
only learning experiences that's what
fails here we'll work over here see so
it's not a failure
this may is like finished you fail this
over so you have to take that that word
away and say okay this is what I gotta
go do rule number six
go do something I'm sure y'all have
heard of this poem oh no you know what's
on my way okay well I'm gonna tell you
cuz none of us have had ever heard of
everyone
FOMO or fear of missing out
we don't say on what we just say fear of
missing out and apparently can be
crippling
for a lot of people and it's getting
more widespread
opposed by Time magazine says it can be
sparked by unhappiness which are over
life and being jealous of the one you
think you see other people because it's
like if you're freaking out because
other people are having fun and you're
sitting there looking at this maybe you
should just take your behind out of the
door and go have some fun yourself rule
number seven have guts but there are
people who whose goal in life was to
instill the positive ideal that you
could go forward that anything you
wanted was yours for the taking you know
with a commitment to hard work and
knowing that it wasn't always going to
be easy and people who taught me that
the hardest thing to be truly in this
world if someone who disagrees with
popular people you know to take
unpopular stances in front of popular
people it's easy to be unpopular with
unpopular people but it's harder to be
unpopular with popular people and then
the people that have been still that in
me also I take my hat off to because
that that I think is the foundation that
has allowed me to do exactly as I please
you know and be and look just like I
wanna
I think of guts as something that like
gives you that Kirk Douglas look but I
think what I mean is the knowledge that
it is okay to feel differently than the
pack that that is a fundamental right
that it's okay to disagree it's better
to be able to disagree and have a
dialogue than to go along with the pack
and be truly unhappy I don't want to be
truly unhappy I mean there's enough out
there to piss me off you know
to bother me I'm sorry there's enough
out there to bother me rule number eight
turn difficulties into advantages you
think your dyslexia got you to where you
are today I'm sure it had a large a
large hand in it yeah and the fact that
since I was born I've always known I
want to pretend to put myself in other
time periods to be able to pretend to be
another species I mean that stuff to me
is interesting and and it helps my mind
excited yeah it's our way of escaping
the real life and I think normal people
can't really do that they have a harder
time I think they have a very hard time
and for that what would you say is the
most challenging part of having this
flux ahead and what advantages do you
think that has given you I think the
advantage is my brain sees and puts
information in my head differently
mm-hmm sometimes more interestingly I
think then then if I saw like everyone
else I think it's less challenging now
because we have some idea about it but I
think the challenge will always be how
we see ourselves not as folks with a
handicap but folks with an interesting
perspective on everything order rule
number nine make your own decisions in
an individual is tough you know people
don't always want to take responsibility
for what they believe and so it's easier
to be a follower sometimes but when it
comes to individuals it's important to
make your own decision you can only make
an intelligent decision about anyone any
group of people once you have had some
experience you have to decide for
yourself whether you are willing to pay
the price of being an individual which
means that people will not always like
the fact that you are making your own
decision
rule number ten the last one before some
very special bonus clips have fun do
people really need small talk to be
happy
researchers found that people who
actually have substantial conversations
I'm more content that idle chitchat can
help you bond with people I'm doing
small talk now you guys need to fill the
air with small talk the silence make you
uncomfortable that's the end of the
questions
now I've got two very special bonus
clips around how to inspire others and
do things because you love it but before
that I want to know what did you learn
from this video
what part of Whoopi's message resonated
the most with you what are you gonna
change in your life or your business
after watching this video make a
commitment leave it down the comments
below I'm really curious to find out it
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clips
I remember wanting to be an actor from
around the age of like five and because
my family was really performative we
used to perform at family gatherings and
stuff but what actually did it for me
was watching the color purple
when I saw Whoopi Goldberg and she
looked like me and I was like oh I could
do this I could do this for a living and
that's when I feel that it really became
a bug
come on come on you know be an actor
because you love to act I'm being active
cuz you think you're gonna get famous
cuz that's luck but if it's what you
want to do with your whole heart and so
come on go everywhere learn everything
learn Shakespeare Shakespeare is great
fun don't be thrown by the words the
words are the same words that we use you
know with a little different
implementation you know write things for
yourself come on it's a great way to
spend time it's a great way to learn
history you know it's a great way to
learn all kinds of things but only come
if you come into play if you're not
coming to play you should get another
gig to supplement your acting raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion can not one drop of myself
work depends on your it's something to
me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details